die ganzen noten kleinen jungs kostenlos
wird euch wo sie denn etwas glaubt
netz.com bahn ein video wie heute ich
hoffe euch gefällt mir jetzt auch
fantastisch bis auf ich sitze hier oben
das ist ja von dachboden wo ich immer
aufnehmen und es ist heute einfach so
fertigt waren hier also die sonne
scheint voll drauf und sie sind
ungelogen graz 27 grad ich mal schätzen
deswegen wird sich ja auch im t shirt
eigentlich welche thema draußen das
wetter ist echt ganz schön aber erst wie
das video gedreht und angetrauten so
läuft und zwar gab immer von mir so vor
drei vier monaten das video music ellis
mit 0 like und viele haben mir halt
gesagt alexion musical es macht macht
man mit instagram bilde ich fand die
idee eigentlich ziemlich gut und
deswegen habe ich euch irgendwie heute
morgen auch gefragt schickt mir nochmal
bei insta ganz viele bilder mit nur
likes um ehrlich zu sein ich dachte da
kommen viel mehr aber ich habe glaube
ich nur eine auswahl aus keine ahnung 50
60 bildern gehabt weil es anscheinend
kaum bilder gibt mit nur leicht
da bin ich wohl der einzige ja ich bin
gespannt wie chance jetzt etwas zusammen
an und ich werde ein bisschen
analysieren und vielleicht mal den ein
oder anderen aufruf starten damals im
dreieck abzugeben oder selber man
leichter zu lassen weil das ist ja schon
traurig wenn man ein schönes bild
verrostet und das irgendwie niemandem
gefällt und kurz auf vorweg ich will
damit natürlich niemanden angreifen oder
so wenn ich jetzt auch immer dein bild
drin habe und dass nun likes leute live
sind absolut nicht wichtig im leben
über 15.000 leicht gibt es übrigens den
feinpapier von denen sich fünf mal sagen
mir jetzt ich diesen beruf hat youtuber
st
ich würds immer leicht um zu sehen ob
euch das gefällt oder nicht oder ob ihr
davon mehr sehen wollt oder sonst aber
generell würde ich sagen die pizza
zünder
juli pizza aber generell würde ich sagen
dass like eine rolle spielen man ist
nicht besser nur weil man vielleicht hat
deswegen hoffe das geht in euren kopf
rein
wir fangen jetzt geht ja gut los das
erste bild kommt von ok ich habe mich
gerade besser dazu entschlossen die
namen zu zensieren weil ich finde es
nicht gut wenn alle aufträge und hätte
deswegen sie hat auf jeden fall zeigt
wie sie das gefühl hat würde ich euch
gar nicht sagen
auf jeden fall kostet fakt trauriger
geschlecht
verkehrt ein bild von ihrem bauch und
kriegt dafür null like kann er ganz sei
näher an die ganzen noten kleinen jungs
was denn los wird euch wo seid ihr denn
was im boot sein laub gehört der mine
von unserer stammte zu ihr ein gutschein
bekommen einer gratis pizza fordert geht
raus an hallo pizza ganzen was ich dazu
auch mal sagen kann sieht auf jeden fall
sehr junges und ich find's gut dass
solch ein bild von einer sagen jetzt mal
zwölfjährigen oder meinetwegen auch
13-jährigen mit nicht unterstützt wird
weil sowas sollte man in diesen jungen
jahren auch kein verkosten oder ok kommt
zum nächsten bild das ist nämlich von
was ich als zunahmen zensieren ich wenn
mein bruder sind doch auf jeden fall
zwei coole brauch so finde ich echt
schade kummer der fußball ist geil
der markt fußball leute da mist jetzt
alle drauf gehen und den mann ein paar
leichter lassen ohne spaß das bild jetzt
so ein leiter stefan ist ein schönes
foto mit wohltaten profil geschickt in
seiner profil bio steht bitte keine leid
verstehe ich jetzt gar nicht so wie du
hast du ein instagram ich meine der
kanzler dann auch ganz normale seiner
gallery abspeichern so trotzdem musste
das werk anzeigen aus ist man alter was
mit ihnen los
ich feiere das kann aber mega gebt euch
das war hebt euch einfach mal seine
haare sind die svm huber und cosplay der
innere organe der seine frisur ist echt
krass
der sieht aus wie dieser wandert übler
route heißt er glaube ich guck das nicht
so viel aber du siehst wirklich 1 1 zu
auf feierlich und wieso wenn man sich so
wie für seine frisur und die frisur ist
zwar jetzt leistung ich würde das nicht
tragen aber ich finde das kann man auch
mal leicht feststellen schreibt diese
kommentare #bpw #bv10 du hast auf jeden
fall eine menge selbstvertrauen
mitgebracht finde ich sehr gut
das ist der liebe tom für mich sieht
echt sympathisch aus und cooles bild und
cooles sie und tom hat leider
die auch wieder heftig estate ag people
hashtag ag gender jetzt meine ernst
gemeinte frage seid ihr dumm
ihr könnt darüber wissen los und man
kann ich doch nicht einfach durch den
selber als andy bezeichnen das finde ich
auf jeden fall sehr schlecht leute mal
an alle diese tests ich bin oder so ich
hab das schon so oft gesagt aber
schottin spiegel denkbar sich heute
wieder gut aus was ist einfach jeden
morgen auch wenn's schwer fällt oder so
das ist wichtig ihr könnt euch mich als
hässlich bezeichnet
so macht was aus euch keine ahnung und
lasst euch nicht von anderen sagen du
bist hässlich weil viel mal kurz sagen
auch wenn es eigentlich rein gar nichts
mit dem thema zu tun was ich vor
landertinger feiert unten hier suchen so
oder so punkte
gut so heute verstehe ich die welt nicht
mehr
ich mein ich guck mir geraten ihr profil
an die hat wirklich nur so fotos wo sie
nichts zu sehen ist also ihr die richtig
zu singen sondern einfach nur ihr körper
und dieses bild hat einfach original 0
likes an die ganzen kleinen notgeilen
jungs seid ihr was denn los mit euch ihr
müsst auf dieses vorgehen unterbreiten
was ist doch immer so das wird auch
aufhält probier's doch mal mit hashtags
und hat ein bild bei vielleicht sehen
dass dann leute instagram besteht doch
eigentlich nur noch auf irgendwelchen
mädels oder irgendwelchen frauen die
sich freizügig zeigen und wie etwa eine
millionen likes dass sie ab 0 likes
meine hoffnung in die menschheit kommt
zu langsam zurück ihrem ersten ich muss
jetzt einmal auf meine ins detail
eingehen und dann ist die hoffnung
wieder verschwunden
[Musik]
ich würde sagen das waren ein paar
instagram bilder mit nur live wenn er
bock hat auf seinen palast nach oben da
und wir sehen uns dann übermorgen wieder
ans netz und entwicklung auf keinen fall
vergessen
haut rein